Lễ kiện nghiệp giữa bên giữa hành tảm ơi năm cách mặt thành công và cuốc khánh 1,2 tháng chiến.
Phát đầu lúc xấu giờ 3 mì phút, thứ 3 ngày 1,2 tháng chiến 1,2 nghìn thuộc dọng hay lắm.
Lễ điểm, khoảng trường 8 đình và một số tiến đường Trung tâm của Do Hanh Nội.
Quý mồ khoảng 8,000 nghìn người thăm sự, không kể lực lượng giữa bên giữa hành.
Chị kế chương trình, xấu giờ 3 mì phút, giữa nước truyền thống, xấu bộ cuốc thòng bộ văn hoá thẻ thao và suy lịch của hợp thực hiện.
Sau giờ 4 mì lắm phút, ní lễ trọc gơ, xấu bộ cuốc thòng thực hiện.
Sau giờ 5 mì phút, kên bố lý gió, sử dụng đại vụ, xấu bộ văn hoá thẻ thao và suy lịch thực hiện.
Mày giờ công nắm phút, diễn văn của lạnh đạo đàn, nhả nước.
Lửa bệ dơ 4 mì lắm phút, chương trình xấu bình xấu hành xấu bộ cuốc thòng điều hành.
Chính dở 4 mồ đồng phút đến mồi dơ, mạnh đồng diễn gệ thọc, xấu bộ văn hoá thẻ thao và suy lịch thực hiện.
Lịch xấu dụng triệt.
Sau giờ 2 mồ đồng, nãy 2 mì bệ hành tâm, xấu phòng nãy 2 mì tâm hành tâm.
Tổng giết, bây giờ, nãy 3 mùi hành tâm, xấu phòng nãy 3 mùi hành tâm.